This lecture is about how we can
evaluate a ranked list.
In this lecture we will continue the
discussion of evaluation.
In particular, we're going to look at
how we can evaluate the ranked list of
results.
In the previous lecture we talked
about.
Precision and Recall.
These are the two basic measures for
quantitatively
measuring the performance of search
result.
But as we talked about
Ranking before, we framed the tax
retrieval problem as a ranking problem.
So,
we also need to evaluate the quality of
a ranked list.
How can we use precision and recall to
evaluate a ranked list?
Naturally, we have to look at the
precision and recall at different cut
offs because in the end the
approximation of relevant documents set
given by a ranked list is determined by
where the user stops browsing, right?
If we assume the user sequentially
browses the list of results, the user
would stop at some point and that point
will determine the set, and then that's
the most important cut off
that will have to consider when we
compute the precision recall without
knowing where exactly the user would
stop, then we have to consider all the
positions where the user could stop.
So let's look at these positions.
Look at this slide and then
let's look at the what if the user
stops at the first document?
What's the precision and recall at this
point?
What do you think?
It's easy to see,
that this document is relevant, so the
Precision is one out of one.
We have got one document and that's
relevant.
What about the recall ?
Note that we assume that there are 10
relevant documents for this query in
the collection, so it's one out of 10.
What if the user stops at the second
position?
Top 2.
The precision is the same - 100%
two out of two in the record
2 out of 10.
What if the user stops at third
position?
Well, this is interesting because in
this case we have not got any
additional relevant document.
So the recall doesn't change.
But the precision is lower because we've
now got a random number.
So what exactly the Precision?
It's two out of three, right?
And recall is the same -
2 out of 10.
So when would we see another point
where the recall would be different? Now if
you look down the list
it won't happen until we have seen
another relevant document.
In this case D5.
At that point, the recall is increased
to three out of 10.
And the precision is a three out of
five.
So you can see if we keep doing this we
can also get to D8 and then we will
have a Precision of four out of eight.
Because there are eight documents, and
four of them are relevant and the
recall is a four out of 10.
Now when can we get a recall of five
out of 10?
Well, in this list we don't have it.
So we have to go down on the list.
We don't know where it is.
But as a convenience, we often assume
that the precision is 0.
The precision is zero at all
the other levels of
Recall that are beyond the search
results.
So of course this is a pessimistic
assumption.
The actual precision would be higher,
but we may make this assumption in
order to have an easy way to compute
another measure called average
precision that we will discuss later.
Now I should also say now here you see,
we make these assumptions that are
clearly not accurate.
But this is usually OK for the purpose
of comparing to text retrieval methods,
and this is for the relative
comparison, so it's OK if the actual
measure or actually actual number
deviates a little bit from the true
number as soon as the deviation is not
biased toward any particular retrieval
method and we are OK, we can still
accurately tell which method works
better, and this is an important point
to keep in mind.
When you compare different algorithms,
the keys to avoid any bias toward each
method, and as long as you can avoid
that, it's OK if you do transformation
of these measures in anyway, so you can
preserve the order.
OK, so we just talked about that
we can get a lot of precision recall
numbers at different positions, so now
you can imagine we can plot a curve and
this just shows on the X axis we show
recalls.
And on the Y axis we show the
precision.
So the precision levels are marked as
0.1, 0.2, 0.3 and 1.0 .
So this is the different levels of
recall.
And the Y axis also has different
amounts that for precision.
So we plotted these precision recall
numbers that we have got as points on
this picture.
Now we can further link these
points to form a curve as you see, we
assumed that all the other precision that
start high level records to be 0 and
that's
why they are down here, right,
So they are zero in this.
The actual curve probably will be
something like this, but as we just
discussed, it doesn't matter that much
for comparing two methods.
'cause this would be an
underestimate for all the methods.
OK, so now that we have this precision
recall curve,
how can we compare 2 ranked lists
right?
So that means we have to compare two PR
curves.
And here I show 2 cases where the
system A is shown in red,
System B is showing blue with crosses.
Alright, so which one is better?
I hope you can see here
System A is clearly better.
Why?
Because for the same level of recall,
it's the same level of recall here, and
you can see the precision point by
system is better than system B,
so there's no question. Indeed, you can
imagine what does the curve look like
for ideal search system.
It has to have perfect precision at all
the recall points, so it has to be this
line.
That would be the ideal system.
In general.
The higher the curve is, the better,
right
The problem is that we might see a case
like this actually happens often like
the two curves across each other.
Now in this case, which one is better?
What do you think?
Now this is a real problem that you
actually might face.
Suppose you build a search engine and
you have old algorithm that's shown
here in blue or system B and you have
come up with a new idea and you test it
and the results are shown in red curve
A.
Now your question is - is your new method
better than the older method?
Or more practically, do you have to
replace the algorithm that you are
already using your in your search
engine with another new algorithm?
So should we use system method A to
replace method B?
This is going to be a real decision
that you have to make. If you make the
replacement, the search engine would
behave like system made here,
whereas if you don't do that,
It will be like a system B.
So what do you do?
Now, if you want to spend more time to
think about this, pause the video and
it's after a very useful to think about
that.
As I said, it's a real decision that
you have to make if you are building
your own search engine,
or if you're working for a company that
cares about search.
Now if you have thought about this for a moment,
you might realize that, well in this
case it's hard to say there was.
Some users might like system A,
some users might like system B.
What's the difference here?
The difference is just that in the
low level of recall in this region,
system B is better, there's higher
precision, but in high recall reading
system A is better.
Now, so that also means it depends on
whether the user cares about the high
recall or low recall, but high
Precision.
And imagine if someone is just going to
check out what's happening today and
you want to find some random in the
news.
Which one is better?
What do you think?
In this case, clearly system B is
better because the user is unlikely
examining a lot of results.
The user doesn't care about high
recall.
On the other hand, if you think about a
case where a user is doing, it's a
literature survey, you're starting a
problem.
You want to find whether your idea has
been started before.
In that case, you emphasize high
recall, so you want to see as many
relevant documents as possible.
Therefore, you might favor system A.
So that means which one is better
actually depends on
users,
and more precisely user's task.
So this means you may not necessarily
be able to come up with one number that
would accurately depict the
performance.
You have to look at the overall picture
yet as I said, when you have a
practical decision to make whether you
replace the algorithm with another,
then you may have to actually come up
with a single number to quantify each
method.
Or when we compare many different
methods in research,
ideally we have one number to compare
them with, so that we can easily make a
lot of comparisons.
So for all these reasons it's desirable
to have one single number to measure
that.
So how do we do that?
And that needs a number to summarize
a range.
So here again, it's the precision
recall curve, right.
And one way to summarize this whole
ranked list for this whole curve is
look at the area underneath the curve.
Right, so this is one way to measure
that, there are other ways to measure
that, but it just turns out that this
particular way of measuring it has been
very popular and has been used since a
long time ago for text retrieval
evaluation.
And this is basically computed in this
way, and it's called Average Precision.
Basically, we're going to take a look
at every different recall point.
And then look after the precision.
So we this is one precision and this is
another with different recall.
Now this we don't count this one because
the recall level is the same.
An we can do then look at this number
and that's the precision at a different
recall level, etc.
So we have all these,
add it up.
These are the provisions that had the
different points corresponding to
retrieving the first relevant document.
The 2nd and then the third, the fourth,
etc.
Now we missed the mini random
documents.
So in all those cases we just assumed
they have zero precisions.
And then finally we take the average.
So we divided by 10 and which is a
total number of relevant documents in
the collection.
Note that here we are not dividing this
sum by 4, which is a number of
retrieved relevant documents.
Now imagine if I divide by 4, what
would happen?
Now think about this for a moment.
It's a common mistake that people
sometimes overlook.
So if we you divide this by 4, it's
actually not very good.
In fact, you are favoring a system that
would retrieve very few rather than
documents, as in that case the
denominator would be very small, so
this would be not a good measure.
So note that this dinominator
is 10.
The total number of relevant documents.
And this will basically compute the
area underneath the curve.
And this is the standard method used
for evaluating a ranked list.
Note that it actually combines recall and
precision, but first we have precision
numbers here.
But second, that we also consider
recall because if you miss the many,
there will be many zeros here.
So it combines precision and recall,
and furthermore you can see this
measure is sensitive to a small change
of a position of a relevant document.
Let's say if I move this relevant
document up a little bit, now it would
increase
this average precision, whereas if
I move any relevant document down,
let's say I move this random document down, then
it would decrease the average precision.
So this is very good because it's a
very sensitive to
the ranking of every relevant document.
It can tell small differences between 2
ranked lists and that's what we want.
Sometimes one algorithm only works
slightly better than another, and we
want to see this difference.
In contrast, if we look at the
precision at the 10 documents.
If you look at this whole set.
What's the precision?
What do you think?
Well, it's easy to see.
That's four out of 10, right?
So that precision is very meaningful
because it tells us
what user would see.
So that's pretty useful, right?
So it's a meaningful measure from a
user's perspective.
But if we use this measure to compare
systems, it wouldn't be good because it
wouldn't be sensitive to where these
four relevant documents are ranked.
if I move them around the precision at
10 is still the same.
Right, so this is not a good measure
for comparing different algorithms.
In contrast, the average precision is
a much better measure.
It can tell the difference of different
difference in ranked lists
in subtle ways.